foreign
yeah welcome everyone
once again
okay I need my slides please
yes
so welcome everyone uh it's paikondi in
pi data Berlin once again
I would like to welcome
1700 attendees we have 1700 attendees we
have 1300 people here in the BCC plus
400 people joining us remotely it's the
biggest conference ever again
you
and
so
I want to welcome you I want to welcome
our sponsors I want to welcome the
organization committee which
is here
I would like to welcome Mike from the
python software for band I would like to
welcome Lear I met her basically at the
Pike Euro python 2014. it was my first
by data and she sold me the T-shirt
right yeah so this is the way of this is
a history of Pi data in this venue as
well so it for me it all started here so
so very welcome
um
we also have to say
we're 100 sold out on site so we're
really sorry I know many people wanted
to join us on site but we have maxed out
the venue so we don't have and had any
more space left
for to get more people
um to join us so we hope you join us
remotely and you enjoy the conference we
try to make the conference as exclusive
as impossible possible also remotely
this both of Discord and many things we
will
here um so but enough about us on the
conference know about you please stand
up if you are the first time around
you sign up wow wow
so
so a very warm welcome to your first
conference
um please say hi to each other if you
haven't been at one of these wonderful
picons or Pi data conferences there's
some basic rules there's no stupid
questions if you need help if you ever
needed just ask one of your fellow
fellow attendees it's a very nice and
this is some people say they came from
the language and stayed for the
community so this is how things work
here and we have the Pac-Man rule
um the Pacman rule let me demonstrate it
here so if people stand together like
this in a circle that's yeah we have to
we didn't we didn't we didn't uh yeah so
Circle yeah we say always say don't do
the circle like this do the circle like
this one say hey how are you yes and
welcome join the conversation this is
the Pacman rule open up your
conversation circles other people can
just join the conversation and I can
guarantee you everybody will learn great
things about being working like that
um another important thing is to know
the conference is run by volunteer
experts so
um somebody helping you on help desk
maybe might be a very experienced data
scientist a volunteer showing you the
way might be just join the community and
language it's very important the
conference is run by volunteers because
we want to be authentic we want to be
inclusive and we want to basically know
all about people in the community so we
can make the best community experience
happening and all the proceedings and
earnings from this conference and go to
the python software for month and
non-focus to support open source and
community activities and now I would
like to to meet the team many are on
stage here and this is the team that
makes an event like this happen with a
lot of work and and I would like you to
please give them a hand
[Applause]
we
if you were out there it was like the
team has really grown to make it even
better and you probably might think this
is where we all come from because it's
Pike on the inpidated Berlin right this
is what you expect us to come from uh
you probably said you had as many
experts and maybe like this but actually
indeed this is the distribution where
people from the committee actually live
and work so we have someone from Japan
who helped in the program team we have
Nidia from Nicaragua she was in the
diversity team we have Leah from non
Focus you're the winner for for East
Austin here and so basically since we
had a big reach out it um yeah so we
said okay it's a global conference it's
a national conference why not also work
globally and I'm I'm really proud of
that and now I would like to give the
word to the program committee
so and
all right
so uh my name is Ricardo Florian and
Alina we had the opportunity we were
giving this nice opportunity to
contribute back to the community and to
organize to be organized in the program
committee
and we started the work back in December
or even before that meeting like twice a
week and
preparing everything out the platform
that you guys use to submit the
proposals this year we got 427 proposals
um we opened for a community voting so
we could find out which are the most
interesting topics that we would like to
have
and got to over 14
000 votes and the acceptance rate after
a reviewing process where we had a penny
of 59 reviewers it was around roughly 27
percent that we accepted
and of course that was a lot of
proposals we got this year I think was
the record that the number of that we
got and it's enough material for
actually two conferences
so of course we would like to extend our
thanks to the reviewers they are also
volunteers they are listed in our
website and especially
thank you for the people who submitted
and I would say especially those who
didn't use chatea GPT and if you
and if you use if you use wisely then
it's okay yeah but we got quite some of
those I would say
so do you yeah
yeah and while we were working in the
committee we also thought why not start
the library a python library to yeah to
improve the work I mean in the end as a
committee you review
um you have to decide what kind of talks
you select you work a lot with pre-talks
which is this platform we were using and
then we thought well we want to
contribute back and make it more
efficient so we developed pythonis so if
you ever want to kind of yeah have your
own conference Community Conference and
use pre-talks then pythonis might be a
nice library that helps you to yeah
interface with pre-talks also interface
with help desk and with Google sheet so
just check it out give it some some
GitHub stars and yeah and some of the
nice statistics we made
pythonis was also used maybe some some
fun facts so we did a word cloud of all
the abstract and who would have thought
data and python are the most common
words so a little consistency check but
now for the for the real statistics I
hand over to Alina
yes but basically these statistics also
matching the keywords that you've seen
in the slides before so we got a many
submissions on the different topics uh
and try to include as much as possible
uh various
topics in the program of course there
are some yeah classic and bigger topics
like python scientific libraries NLP
computer vision machine learning but
also as you can see there are smaller
groups and we will try to find the room
for all of them
and some statistics on our speakers
also not surprisingly since we are in
Berlin the majority are coming from
Germany but not not only and not only
from Europe so we welcome you all
[Applause]
when you when we are when you are in the
session regardless if you're here on
site or if you joined us remotely we use
slido again
um here's a link you can just go to
slider.com the the code is up there
um and you can just go to slido ask
questions
um please make sure also these questions
will be there are under code of conduct
please ask nicely on the session shares
we'll pick the questions and read them
to the speaker we did that last year it
was very good
um and it worked worked really well and
yeah so if you got it we we can find
also find it on Discord
lightning talks who knows what lightning
talks are
I I thought so yes so lightning talk to
say a lightning talk is like we have
like this stage for like five minutes
and you can talk about everything which
is basically appropriate so but no
marketing it's really hard because
basically lightning talks are very open
it can yeah lightning talks about
going to the world's meditation it's
it's lightning talk you have five
minutes
no marketing no recruiting
um first one first first is fifo first
in first out the lightning talk board
you have to sign up here with the pen
it's at the next to the python software
for band table downstairs in B and yeah
and we have five minutes and if you run
a conference please keep it short and we
maximize conference announcement to just
two minutes
right and we have lightning talks today
and tomorrow
I also would like to thank the European
Union for sponsoring us
actually true
um so and I would give like to give the
word to Eva
who was responsible for sponsoring yes
we'd like to thank our sponsors this
year's sponsors it's 31 sponsors this
year and you can meet them at the booth
outside and
um there are different categories so our
Diamond sponsors are Deutsche Post group
jet brains Ebay mobile
and snowflake
and yeah give them a warmer Plus
foreign
and then we have our Platinum sponsors
and also
our gold sponsors
and our flavor and diversity sponsors
give them all a warm Applause and feel
free to meet them all at the booth and
thanks to all of them for making this
conference financially possible
thank you very much go by the wolf to
have nice budgets I heard even there's a
PlayStation 5 to win I heard just check
out the booth find out who has the
coolest stuff
now I would like to give the word to
Valentina who is responsible for the
volunteers on site
hi um I'm the coordinators of of the
so we have 50 volunteers on site here
working throughout the three days of the
conference
and we sent out we also have three
remote volunteers
basically we sent out a call for our
volunteers uh earlier in January
and we had about 80 people a 80
applications
and so why do we need volunteers first
we cannot do all this without them
we you have met them already they they
were the ones who handed out your badge
at the registration desk
they will hand out t-shirts later later
they some of them are actually here
making sure we comply to the regulations
to the fire regulations
some of them they will help us help out
speakers or the session chairs they have
a big variety of tasks
and
[Music]
um
who who are them uh who are they so we
selected based on different criteria
um first of all we want to be we want
yeah inclusive so we selected them among
women and underrepresented groups uh
second we selected mostly students or
the ones who cannot afford a ticket
and third the most important we selected
the ones who were mostly most motivated
and enthusiastic to help out and also to
give back to the community
and yes we want to also grow the
community
and so you recognize all of us by this
t-shirt color
um
some of them are here some are actually
busy still at the registration probably
but they really deserve a big thank you
and a big round of applause
and now now I like I would like to
introduce you to the code of conducting
yes uh we do have a code of conduct team
um I'd like to to invite here Paloma and
Ivana and Paola as well
um so I hope all of you uh have read the
code of conduct because we do have one
and we care about it because we want
everybody to feel at home at this
conference and feel comfortable however
we know that with so many people there
may be situations that are not as
comfortable as we would like them to
have and for that type of situations we
are here
so there is a an email address that you
can reach out here it's COC at pycon De
that goes to to all of us and we have a
few extra people as a backup that we can
can reach out to if a situation that is
difficult needs to be moderated yeah so
we are mainly here to to listen and to
um and to see what can be done uh
whatever is needed in that particular
spot thank you
and you you can reach out in person and
there's also an email address where you
can reach out it's easy to remember COC
at pycon De
um another very important mission for us
is video so I would like to introduce
you to the video team
hi everyone I'm Michael and we are the
video committee for this year's pycon
and it is our job as the video committee
to make sure that all the amazing talks
over the next three days are accessible
to everyone through our live streams
and yeah I'm being part of the video
committee is awesome because we get to
include as many people as possible to be
part of the community in this conference
and not just us lucky ones being here
today
and of course we help also spread the
knowledge and wisdom of all the experts
here
um even after the conference by
uploading the videos online
so yeah we're very excited for this
year's pycon if you spot anything uh
wrong with the stream or any issues let
us know on Discord
so with that being said Thank you and
yeah speaking of Discord I think
thank you yeah
maybe maybe one short comment there will
be many many questions when the videos
will be uploaded they will be uploaded
it just may take some time uh don't ask
hundreds of questions so when when other
videos we will work on it is able to see
the streams right yeah so um if you
don't fit into a room just sit somewhere
with your laptop or maybe in a group and
then you can watch all the streams but
please don't share the link on on
Twitter that would be really bad right
yep we trust each other Just One Last
Thing uh a big shout out for our Italian
team that is behind there making the
recordings preparing
and yeah these videos are actually
important if I made my might add an
adding toad actually we were traveling
in a train and talking about the
conference and there was a fellow
traveler said I'm sorry I heard you what
is they're going to the conference it
actually turns out he made himself a
machine learning engineer watching
conference videos from this very
conference so this may make sense so
it's it was quite amazing to see yeah
it's not only theories happening real
life next to you in the train that's
really good so I would like to introduce
you to Olaf from Olaf
here now to the communication team
here you go all right yeah
hi everyone yeah I get that a lot it's
Ola not Olaf hola so yeah sorry my my me
and names that's always like hola I know
you and I know your nickname and so
we'll find out why the nickname is like
that certainly yeah we had a
Communications team um we're in charge
of website Discord and Discord and
Twitter we will be posting a lot of
information on Discord to to help you
out if you have any question you can go
to the help Channel and we'll be able to
answer some of your questions hopefully
and if you haven't registered in Discord
yet please and do so because there are
quite a number of information there that
we have put to to help folks during the
conference and then also check out check
us out on Twitter Twitter your friends
let them know that this is happening so
they can also hook up
and yes certainly
um there are a number of
um things to do and things not to do so
um no spamming no random messages to
people you don't know essentially we're
saying don't talk to strangers but
that's not it and things like that so
yeah if you have any question please get
to us in on the health Channel and we'll
be able to help you out thank you right
thank you very much
and now we would like to introduce the
steering committee
so yes
that's us for and you want to do yeah
um yeah so we are the steering community
so what we are we responsible for so we
we did this call for organizers that
help us recruit all these people behind
so yeah that was a really great
experience and then we helped onboard
them and finally we make sure the things
run smoothly and yeah but all the great
work was done by most of them so yeah
thank you that's it thank you
it's just there's just one bad thing so
one member really doesn't hold to his
promises so he said this year I won't do
that much again but he failed completely
sorry again Alexander did all of the
stuff on his own no no no no no no
that's not true but uh I had the biggest
team ever thank you so much stuff
so and now uh
I would like to introduce you to the
diversity team
hello everyone so this is nilia and this
is the diversity team
um
thank you everyone
so we were in charge of launching the
financial aid program that means that we
needed to review all the applications
and go through detail by details to
select the candidates for the for the
financial aid program also we handle all
the communication
and this year we launched a new
initiative in which we are going to give
three lighting space lighting talk
spaces to three NGO so they can present
their work during the conference and we
also are in charge or coordinating the
pilated events
a little bit of the stats so this year
we receive 119 submissions there were so
many disturbing applicants but in the
end we accepted 38 people and as you can
see there is a division between European
Mediterranean we have 19 there on-site
ticket we have 11 we have seven
transcontinent transcontinent top people
this is a new category that we added
this year and one person that is
enjoying the online ticket actually the
people that were on accepted day
actually can join the conference online
and they can do it remotely and and some
of the stats is that as you can see we
have a very diverse
applicants and acceptance and you can
see that we have 19 countries and an
important stat is that 40 of the
accepted applicants are female so that's
great
and this couldn't be possible without
the help of our diversity sponsors and
we were able to reach up to 20 000 Euros
this year and and we were able to
provide on-site attendance for 37 people
and so we would like to thank python
software Foundation aeropyton Society so
maybe we can give a random class
and also we have energy and metal blue
gender flicks innovax and jungle also
Adriana Plus
so yeah
thank you so much
yeah
thank you very much
so I am the conferences run under the
roof of the Python software for band
um and I would like to bring my fellow
chair Mike on stage
thank you very much
I would like to introduce python Surfer
for band so we are Association here in
Germany but we represent
at the legal entity it actually runs a
conference and we represent the
community represent to be
try to serve the community that might be
the right wording so the German speaking
community and we're behind pycon de and
Pi data here in Berlin but also your
side by in parcel and we run some
ball caps in addition to this we also
have Grant programs so if you do open
source with python in the German
speaking area you can apply for money
and actually give out money on a regular
basis to do Sprints and other events so
if you would like to learn more about
the python so far but maybe even become
a member and support us we do have a
boost out there so I'm really sitting
there most of the time on some of my my
colleagues there so you can ask us and
would be nice if you come by and maybe
become a member of the pricing software
for Ubuntu
as Mike said we have a table downstairs
you can talk to Mike Klaus is here
Teresa is also in the board you might
remember her from remotely last year she
actually made it in person this year
which is awesome yes so yeah and now I
would like to welcome Leah from them
Focus
foreign
thanks it is so fantastic to be in
Berlin again it's been a few years since
I've been here and it is great as
Alexander mentioned 2014 was our very
first Pi data Berlin event here at the
BCC brings back lots of memories to be
back here and it's so nice to see the
incredible growth of the community so
congratulations to you and to get a
local Meetup organizers for growing and
and supporting this community I'd like
to also thank the organizers and to
thank the sponsors thank huge thank you
to the speakers
you all make this event possible and
we're very grateful for that and also to
you the community it's like I said it's
fantastic to have you here to see the
growth of this event and to see where it
is today
just a show of hands and then focus is
here to support these projects that's
what we do that's why we're here to
provide
support services for the projects how
many of you are contribute to any of
these projects
show of hands quite a few huge thank you
thank you to you we um we invite all of
you to contribute to projects
um it's incredibly important to make
sure there is that user contributor
pipeline that is active that's the way
we make sure our projects are
sustainable in addition to the support
services and of course the incredible
work the contributors and maintainers do
we're here to support them but one thing
that we make sure that we work with our
projects on and that is very important
to them to have a clear entry point for
new contributors so check out the
projects go to their sites go to their
GitHub Pages look and see how you can
contribute both code and non-code
contributions are incredibly welcome so
we invite you to do that
and we have let's see let me advance
next slide also to just get involved in
Num Focus we have some great volunteer
communities that are leading several
initiatives that we have we have um it's
not up here but we have volunteer
committees that are
um working on our small development
grant program that we provide to our 60
sponsored and our 60 Affiliated projects
so that's a volunteer run committee also
our Affiliated project selection
committee are diversity and scientific
Computing committee
we also are very involved with Google
summer of code and season of docs and a
number of other initiatives so we invite
you all to just to get get involved to
reach out
and again a huge thank you to our
meetups around the world for organizing
for sharing knowledge and for creating
events such as this one so we've got
um a ton of Pi data Meetup members and
chapters around the world and then
focused as continue to support that
initiative and encourage you to get
involved in your Regional Regional
Meetup so thank you so much for your
contribution just being here and
supporting the work we're doing stop by
the booth Samina is also here from num
Focus we would
um yeah we would love the opportunity to
chat with you more thanks
[Applause]
for your thank you Leah for like it's
like more than a decade of non-focused
work now right please give a free hand
to Leah thank you very much
but as Lear said we would be basically
nothing without the community and
meetups and user groups and I would like
to
everybody who runs a Meetup who is
involved who who was involved try to
build like a meet-up please stand up
please stand up no meetups here meet up
auras meetups you run a meet up I knew
that Noah come on yes so these are all
organizers who make a community thriving
and it's a lot of work it takes a lot of
energy so please give them a big hand
so so
and it's also like if you have a local
community group you can also have a
channel on Discord just reach out to us
to one of the admins we can give you
like an
um a channel on Discord and actually I
was attending Pi data Global online and
I met people who never heard about our
very local Pi datas with West Meetup in
Heidelberg which were from Heidelberg so
it's a good way to connect also to meet
up and now we have the Pac-Man rule
again
because it's been a lot of information
and this one is very important so we're
going we're here to learn to present but
also to to socialize and to network and
you make things way more easier for shy
people like me if you always make some
space when you're talking right so you
start talking with people and then you
make some space for people just to join
and contribute
talking about socializing
you might be wondering what's these
little things on the batches
these are data portraits and it's the
the data surprise that we promised in
the registration
I don't know if you remember it in the
registration you had the name last name
affiliation blah blah blah and then some
really interesting questions
like
so all this animation is not working
we're missing an image Alex the image oh
I'm sorry oh something went wrong okay
I'll fix that talk keep talking
um so
keep talking without the image so what
what is it actually it's a data portrait
I know I have somebody heard about the
idea of the data portrait
somebody nobody
Christian
good so in this little symbols we have
or I have encoded the answers you gave
to those questions the questions were
for instance what is the area of python
how long did you travel to come to
Berlin how do you like your water do you
like working remotely or on site if you
had to choose a superpower which would
it be if you want to play games which
games
and the solution to this one is have
in the image that is missing
but also we have some sheets in the
Pilates Booth where you have the
solution
to the obvious categories
to the three non-obvious categories
we're making a real quiz out of it so
you have until the end of the day before
the lightning talks to find out what do
the colors
of the the big python snakes are yeah so
the big the bigger snake is what is your
area of python the first one
and we can solve one just one together
so what is the blue snake
what is the blue snake the area of
python
show the presentation now yes sorry yeah
if we fixed it sorry for that so
the blue snake
data yeah so
and I tell it because it's like 40 of
the participants so that's easy yeah so
for all the all the parties in white
yeah
you
have to find what is the the matching
category
same for the games
and for the superpowers
if you solve it you can put the sheer in
a box that is also the Pilates booth and
today in before the lightning talks we
will be raffling uh two times a set of
designers notebook together with a set
of postcards to so that you practice
making your own
data sketches okay so you have until the
lightning talks to find out what are the
categories just a spoiler the two the
two few uh smallest categories have like
10 people so you'll have to talk to a
lot of people to find them right
and everybody's welcome to participate
so only Alex is not and you and me yeah
so
Ladies as well yeah
so no no no no not yet don't start yet
don't start yet
wait wait wait until this is over we
still have just a couple of points we
mentioned a special event for by ladies
so we have a Pilates stand throughout
the conference where you can meet um
fellow Pilates members there's a pie
ladies panel on diversity here tomorrow
everybody's welcome to participate come
and hear a discussion about diversity
we have a workshop on Tuesday this one
is exclusive for Pilates members so be
sure to sign up to Pilates if you
haven't to participate on the workshop
and there's lunch on Wednesday and more
information on the Pilates stand as well
thank you very much Paula thank you
okay some more orientation around the
venue first this is the this is the BCC
the when you and since we are in the BCC
again I would also take like to take the
opportunity to thank the whole BCC team
again for the call of great
collaboration we had again this year
especially to Pia Michelle Christian and
everybody else from the team uh please
give them a big hand as well
so as you can see we're now on the top
sea floor this is the couples are sea
floor below USB and downstairs is a a is
where you entered when you picked up
your badge
um we have General neutral toilets on
Level A and C they're also labeled
we have quiet rooms on levels B and C
they're in the in the corners on this
side so if you go downstairs we have
four quiet rooms where you basically can
just like take your time listen to some
music relax if you're like overflooded
with information or if you have to run
some work to attend to but it's quiet
rooms and as the name said please be
quiet in the room and also with typing
try to be considerate with people around
you who might want to take a break from
the conference and a lot of
communication
we have lunch served this level is
served on levels B and C so above here
and on there we have lunch served we
again
um offer a vegetarian and a vegan menu
here at the venue
um we it's a tradition we're doing it
for years and it's also very good for
sustainability so that's why we settled
again for this great menu and the BCC
kitchen is great anyway so
so you will find out later and coffee
breaks there's coffee stay coffee
station drinks all around so if you see
a fridge and there's bottles free feel
free to take one
um so we have light strings available
all day so this was the good news about
the PCC now coming to the bottoms
um no it's very important for security
and fire regulations
if a room overcrowds there is no sitting
on the floor there is no standing in the
room so sometimes it happens there's
more people who want to see you talk
then I can enter
please don't even try to persuade a
volunteer at the door please respect
what they tell you and if you have a
seat and you sit you're all good if not
please go outside and we have the
opportunity I also have the option to
you can just watch the stream live
um so
um yes please do that also I would like
to thank under pressure and the pressure
does all the swag so you can and I will
yeah so tomorrow you can pick up your
t-shirts if you ordered one it's
important you have to if you ordered one
um you can pick it pick it up at the
registration from tomorrow today or
tomorrow after lunch
um you can may only pick up the ticket
you ordered which the size you actually
ordered which is coded on this on your
badge
um and then one more thing and then
we're basically almost done we have a
social gathering tomorrow
um we have a social gathering tomorrow
at half past six oh wow so much exciting
half for six here directly after
lightning talks in the BCC
you will need to register for that for
just like 10 euros I would like to thank
octopus energy for making this event
happening for electric possible like
because there are the sponsor for our
social Gathering here it's limited to
attendees only you're unfortunately not
able to bring in any friends from
outside
um we looked into many other options
around here for social Gathering or
social event but it was impossible this
year we're sorry but we're very happy to
that the BCC offered us to host the
social Gatherings with drinks and snacks
and you are welcome we have 600
we have a capacity of 600 for this event
so please
get a ticket and you can pick up your
wristband for the ticket tomorrow and
now you can in a minute you can check
your inbox because we just like send you
how to you can purchase a ticket by
email and that's it
enjoy the conference very welcome and
thank you all